[Music]
okay so in vietnam
uh there's a little bit of a scandal
going on i don't know you guys know how
much the average person makes a month in
vietnam isn't it like 300 bucks or
something yeah basically it's it's not
much it's like 150 dollars
and wow
i love vietnam the minister of uh public
health
was just in a video with salt bay oh i
saw that with the gold tomahawk steaks
right fed gold tomahawk steaks
um while a bunch of people in vietnam
are like yo [ __ ] you we don't make
that kind of money we can't afford this
[ __ ] have you ever seen the receipts to
the stakes what is it how much them
shits cost how much those bills are like
tens of thousands of dollars actually
actually those bills are hella expensive
but they're usually on the wine bottles
oh
it's not usually the steak so the steak
is only like two hundred dollars so yeah
this is the you know filter vertically i
hate gold flake stuff dude where did you
go to his restaurant actually had a
flavor right now oh the gold flake
steaks got it get the [ __ ] out of here
with the gold flakes dude damn wait by
the way loki
i don't fully understand why people are
mad
if like
somebody's just eating this well because
he's the vietnamese public health
minister he makes 700 a month
the average vietnamese person makes 150
and they feel like it's a flagrant like
oh shoot they're feeding
but how do they know that he paid for
this like what if it was like an event
like they're like oh come through well
he's not that's even better than he he
looks like i don't even know what's
going on doesn't it
oh wow i mean politics-wise that's like
kind of a dumpster communism communism
does work guys look like you could
[ __ ] you could really make it that's
actually part of what's funny about it
you can really make it in communism is
because he was also um seen in glasgow
paying tribute to the grave of karl marx
and after karl marx how the hypocrisy is
amazing incredible it's incredible um
he's considered vietnam's most one of
their most powerful officials he's in
charge of police and agencies who
scrutinize corruption and dissent so a
lot of people are saying hey hey more
corruption
corruption
of course
damn dude but you know what was weird
when i went out there
it is so opposite from the u.s because
like you know out here like it's like
communism is bad it's our enemy all that
stuff right but out there
it's it's opposite land like all their
um yeah the communists won yeah so like
but i mean what country have do you have
access to as an american
where it's like opposite land everyone
else is america's ally right so like
when i went there i was just mind blown
like i get it
but i we never like this is how
privileged americans are you don't go to
countries where they don't cater to you
every [ __ ] country in the world
that has a high tourist kind of
area they cater to americans
it's one of the first countries that i
went to where i'm like yo they cater to
the french they cater to the russians
the chinese
but no one really speaks english here
and like everything's got red stars and
everything looks like [ __ ]
communist wonderland
and i was i was like this is this is
really a different country joe's like
this is my kind of country
i'm into this the gold tomahawk stick
that we saw being eaten is worth
approximately two g's like 1900 bucks
ugh
um it's at the new sir at steakhouse in
knightsbridge london where salt bay i
guess is
um he was visiting the restaurant which
is even better after attending a united
nations climate change summit in glasgow
so then you know that's also part of
like how beef and like cow farts are
contributing to climate change it's a
little hypocritical sure it's a lot of
hypocritical and then he also went to
karl marx's grave in the same
trip a little hypocritical guy's a
legend and you know they should build a
[ __ ] statue frankly because which
they probably will and i hope they do
but no yeah he he gets paid 700 but then
you know he's sitting here affording a
1900 just for the steak 1900 for the
steak
you know those ironic or like you know
like
when i was out there i went to a um
coffee chain that was coffee that was
communist themed and they have a chain
that's all like you walk in it's got
like pictures of like the war everyone's
[ __ ] shooting [ __ ] you could buy
communist merch like the red star with
the hat like this [ __ ] all that and then
they got cute little desserts like
coconut coffee and ube coffee
but it was i'm sure it was good though
it was [ __ ] amazing
i'm sitting in here drinking this
coconut coffee and i'm looking at the
walls and there's just like this
communist propaganda war scenes
all this [ __ ] and i'm just like this is
[ __ ] dope yeah remember though to be
fair in all political idealisms they all
in their ideology they're the worst guys
yeah they all work and the ideology but
the application
that's
that's always gonna be [ __ ] it really
doesn't matter like you would pick pick
the best governmental [ __ ] ideology
and then have the wrong appliers to it
right same [ __ ]
so so which one works the best anthony
i think whatever works to make your
people happy in your country and keep
you protecting and keep your families
fed so if it works it works if it
doesn't it doesn't i mean we we over
here
tout that democracy is the best and we
have
every problem in the world as well all
of us do
sure but thank you in generalized
ideology of our country
is all i'm saying yeah i don't need to
get political with it all i'm saying you
went way political holy [ __ ] well it's
because he's talking about like
communist merch but i'm like i think
it's ironic i think that's just merch
you know what i'm saying it's not like
we have like democratic merch oh yes we
do brother but it makes sense because
mania
basically ranted against capitalists he
hate [ __ ] industrialists he hated
capitalists he hated commerce right so
then
it's just so ironic right like a coffee
shop that has cute desserts all these
things and it's kind of
it's it yeah we have merch that's
political but that's because we're
capitalists we're pro-capitalism we sell
mark's merch it's funny too it's
hilarious it's just funny it has nothing
to do with even taking the stance it's
just funny it's just yeah the irony it's
like this situation right like you go to
karl marx and you're like yeah awesome
and then you go and [ __ ] eat a golden
steak afterwards of course you want to
yeah it's like going to church and then
right after you're doing an orgy with
all your friends and [ __ ] it's like
which also happens it happens but the
irony i think is just hilarious it's
like
that's it yeah
i don't know so yeah only two months ago
ho chi minh city experienced food short
food shortages and overwhelmed hospitals
during a covered lockdown so that's part
of like what's informing the local
public's ire about this i think yeah so
point is the guy shouldn't have [ __ ]
got caught on camera that's exactly it
it's like all it [ __ ] is it's like it
is what it is my man gavin newsom dude
getting [ __ ] pop going to going to uh
the restaurant without a mask on i'm
like you can't take a good man down yeah
it's like getting caught is what makes
you a fool that's it like avenue i'm
getting yeah at the restaurant french
laundry yeah
trying to enjoy a twelve hundred dollar
meal plate come on
is there ever a country where the
leaders are
not corrupt because i feel like that's
normal
murder us yeah if you like
who's corrupt name one person over there
japanese boy
somehow i thought he's great name one i
don't know any country where the
politicians don't get caught being
[ __ ] hypocrites oh maybe like they
all scandinavia somewhere maybe they're
the only ones that run it right now they
just take different kinds of surveys
that make them look happier than that
yeah different the wording is it's
always a [ __ ] survey they said in
scandinavia they're all happy yeah [ __ ]
off to me it's not about people it's
about human beings and if you give us
power we will do stupid [ __ ] with it
uncheck power that's all it is it's not
a political thing because i feel like
every [ __ ] country has a scumbag
leader if people know they can get away
with something they will continue to
uncheck power and to be completely
honest it's the scumbags
in the same analogy as like nice guys
finish last it's the scumbags or or the
more aggressive or the whatever the [ __ ]
people that end up like doing more
impactful things good or bad scumbags
change the world more thank you anthony
we appreciate it
crazy people do crazy things
the scumbags
are bold enough to make it and until
they think that they deserve that thing
or do you think scumbags are attracted
to power because they want to do stupid
[ __ ] without being blamed for i don't
know what does the dancer think
what does the white privilege think
where who's that
where's that